So with that, with that notion of a concept as functions or as mappings from
objects to membership in a set we have a particular target concept. And the
only difference between a target concept and
the general notion of concept is that
the target concept is the thing we're
trying to find. It's the actual answer. All
right? So, a function that determines whether something is a car
or not, or male or not, is the target concept. Now
this is actually important, right, because we could say that. We
have this notion in our head of things that are cars
or things that are males, or thing, or people who are
credit worthy but unless we actually have it written down somewhere
we don't know whether it's right or wrong. So there is
some target concept we're trying to get of all the concepts
that might map pictures or people to true and false.
>> Okay, so if you trying to teach me what tallness is so
you have this kind of concept in mind of these, these things are
tall and these things are not tall. So you're going to have to
somehow convey that to me. So how are you going to teach me?
>> So that's exactly the, well that's what comes up
with the rest of these things that we're defining here.
>> Okay.
>> So let me tell you what the next four things
are then you can tell me whether that answers your question.
>> Got it.
>> How about that? OK, so we've got a notion
of instances, input, we've got a notion of concepts. Which
take input and maps into some kind of output. And
we've got some target concepts, some specific function from
particular idea that we're trying to find, we're trying to
represent. But out of what? So that's where the hypothesis
comes in. And in fact I think it's better to
say hypothesis class. So that's the set of all concepts
that you're willing to entertain. So it's
all the functions I'm willing to think about.
>> So why wouldn't it just be all possible functions?
>> It could be all possible functions
and that's a perfectly reasonable hypothesis class. The
problem with that is that if it is all possible functions it may be very, very
hard for you to figure out which function is
the right one given finite data. So when
we actually go over decision trees next I think it will be kind of clear why
you need to pick a specific hypothesis class.
>> Okay.
>> So let's return to that in a little
bit but it's an excellent question. So, conceptually in the
back of your head until we, we come to
specific examples, you can think of hypothesis class as simply
being all possible functions in the world. On the
other hand, even so far just the classification learning, we
already know that we're restricting ourselves to a subset of
all possible functions in the world, because all possible functions
in the world includes things like x squared, and that's regeression.
And we've already said, we're not doing regression. We're doing classification.
So already hypothesis classes all functions we care about and maybe
it's all classification functions. So we've already picked a subset. So we
got all these incidences, got all these concepts, we want to
find a, a particular concept and we've got this set of
functions we're willing to look at. So how are we going
to determine what the right answer is. So if you try to
answer Micheal's question that we do that in machine learning is with
a sample or another name for which I prefer is a training set.